yo blackhead podcast man this kid right
here
he got a big song you know you might
know him ddg cat man
hey how how good does it feel to like uh
finally have a song where like
it's you know you've you've been making
so much music for so long and like
you got a record just really got legs
like it's
feeling like a hit man yeah this feels
like a hit
i mean i gotta go record off this r b
song i made
right right and that that was your first
plaque i saw you guys post about that
earlier this year
yeah so but that took a little minute
but this
this one was quick because it's already
gold right this is about gold yeah it's
already gold i just didn't get the um
the plaque yeah the plaque but you gotta
wait till it just goes platinum it's on
its way yeah
i want the platinum to go cool but i
already got it now
yeah congrats man like i know you put
the record out and then it started to
kind of take off and you put blueface on
the remix like when you did the record
did you like have any idea that
this was the one for you mm-hmm you like
knew it off the rip
because it was just catchy like it was
elekaji i had no writers
i wrote everything myself i was just in
the
booth freestyling yeah you know what i
want to give you that props
because a lot of people who you know
might be from your background like use a
lot of writers and
you i me i've seen you in the studio you
write all your own [ __ ]
yeah i truly like i tried to use writers
but i don't really
it's not me you know what i mean it's
like i feel like i'm
a way better writer myself you know what
i mean i know what i went through
unless you believe it yeah i know it's
your story yeah i know how i want to
word it i know how i want to
project it you know what i mean so i
feel like i'm just
getting better and better